We've just gone through how we protect specific vulnerabilities in systems and so forth,
where you know, how do you protect against emanation?
where you know, how do you protect against emanations and how do you protect against
single points of failure and so forth.
Now let's talk more overall, how do you protect systems?
How do you protect overall systems like an entire mobile device, an entire desktop,
a laptop, or even an entire server?
And the simple way to think about this is that these are wildly complex systems.
Like, even take an example, like my phone.
What hardware and software is in a device like this?
They are remarkably complex devices.
From a hardware perspective, we've got a CPU, we've got RAM, we've got tons of storage.
How about even just from a radio as perspective, how many radios are in this?
Well, is your Wi-Fi?
There's your cellular?
There's your Bluetooth?
There's your RFID?
I mean, that's just four radios right there.
There could be more.
And then from a software perspective, we have a very complicated operating system.
We have multiple apps running on top of that.
What I'm trying to get at is that any of these types of devices, even mobile devices,
and especially after something like a server, they are extremely complex devices.
So how do we go about securing such a complex device?
Well, it's a concept John has already talked about.
To protect anything, you break it down into its components.
And then you protect each of those components.
The more valuable the system, the more time you're going to spend subdividing it
into more and more smaller components.
Rather than just looking at the CPU, you could look at parts of the CPU.
Rather than just looking at the operating system as a whole, you could look at the libraries,
the kernel, the drivers.
You break it down into its components and you secure each of those components.
Here's a good question for you.
You know any devices made up of hardware, software, and so forth?
Where is it hardest to detect vulnerabilities?
This is an exam question that's come up recently.
Where is it hardest?
Hardware.
And the reason being is that we have very well established practices and expertise
in how to detect software malware on our systems as an example.
But there's very few organizations that I've ever come across that will, for instance,
look at a new server that's arrived, just look at every chip on that motherboard
to make sure that someone hasn't installed something in the hardware or some routines in the firmware.
So hardware is, if you've got a question on that, hardware is where it's most difficult to detect vulnerabilities.
Now when we think about when I say to you, you know, you should secure components,
what do I actually mean by that?
And how do you decide what controls to put in place and to what, you know, to what,
how much effort to put into place for controls?
Ultimately what it comes down to is based on organizational relevance.
So security controls need to be based on how valuable.
By the way, that term organizational relevance, what does that really mean?
Well, it means what does this system, this process do with an organization?
What's its organizational relevance, which implies value?
Watch out for that in the exam.
If you see something that says like organizational relevance, it's implying how valuable the system is.
And so we implement controls based on the value of the system, the process.
Specific to mobile systems, things like cell phones, there's one particular technology that I want to talk about.
And that is MDM mobile device management software.
It's essentially like installing big brother on your phone.
It allows a corporation to install a little agent on a device.
The MDM software is an agent that gets installed on an endpoint, like a phone.
And then that software agent allows the corporation to monitor the device,
to implement, to require certain controls.
The MDM software, for instance, will enforce whole drive encryption,
will enforce strong passwords, things like that.
And even things like remote white.
So that's MDM software.
And it can even go to the point of if a device isn't in compliance.
And this is used a lot where organizations allow BYOD or CYOD
bring your own device, carry your own device.
If an organization is allowing people to bring in their personal phones,
it's a very good idea to install this MDM software on those devices,
to make sure that those devices are secure before they're allowed to connect to
and obtain information from the corporate network.
Now, a final piece I want to talk about here.
And this is applied to whenever you want to protect any sort of system.
You go through this process of hardening.
And we've talked about this a couple times now, right?
It's this concept of going through a device, looking very carefully at the configuration,
making sure all the patches are in place,
disabling unnecessary services, installing the appropriate security controls
like anti-mower, host-based firewall, host-based IDS IPS.
It's going through a checklist and locking down any type of device.
And this concept of hardening absolutely applies to how you secure a mobile device,
a laptop, a server.
So there you go. That's how you do a better job of addressing vulnerabilities and systems.